the 2008 horror film the strangers has
become a disturbing classic and an
excellent example of the home invasion
genre of horror lock the door and join
us as we explore the meaning of the
film's dark nihilistic ending
kristen and james ride in uncomfortable
silence it's a cool night in february
and the pair are making their way from a
friend's wedding reception to james's
summer home james was so sure that
kristen was going to accept his marriage
proposal kristen's tear-stained face
says it all where do they go from here
there's a knock on the door a blonde
woman bathed in shadow asks for tamara
after an awkward exchange they send her
on her way james attempts to gather his
thoughts and leaves on a night drive
leaving kristin alone in the house then
suddenly another knock more insistent
this time
kristen grabs a knife and starts
charging her phone the landline is dead
and she can't shake the feeling that
someone is in the house so begins the
strangers which barrels forward with
unrelenting energy pitting the
emotionally strained couple against
three masked assailants james returns to
find kristen a mess and he soon finds
out why together they attempt to survive
in their own home defend themselves and
call for help all to no avail at the end
of their terrifying night james is
missing and kristen is badly injured her
attempts to signal for help from a
remote radio are a bust and upon
returning to the house the power cuts
out limping and surrounded by the masked
intruders kristen attempts to find james
only to be knocked out by the towering
male in the group she awakens tied to a
chair next to james distraught and
defeated with one searing question
why
kristin wakes up to the sound of pinup
girl opening the drapes warm sunlight
floods the room kristen grunts against
her tight restraints kicking and
whimpering as her three masked
assailants stand silently over her and
the defeated james we tend to expect
horrific things to take place under the
cover of darkness things that slink
creep and strike while we're sleepy
vulnerable and alone evolutionary
psychologists have theorized that our
fear of the dark lingers from the days
when human beings weren't at the top of
the food chain when nocturnal predators
were a real threat horror films take
advantage of our instinctual fear of the
dark allowing our imaginations to run
wild and conjure up worst case scenarios
in genre cinema horrific things tend to
lurk in the shadows that said there's no
shortage of horror film baddies that
work in the light the man eating shark
and jaws didn't confine its reign of
terror to the shadows and neither do the
trio of killers in the strangers and
this is precisely what makes the climax
of their murderous assault so disturbing
they open the curtains before killing
kristin and james unafraid and
unconcerned with the possibility that
some prying neighbor might see the fact
that the stranger's ends bathed in
sunlight is both unexpected and
terrifying further cementing the film's
core theme that random acts of violence
are exactly that random this isn't the
kind of evil that is miraculously
banished by the sun
there are few glimmers of hope
throughout the strangers one of them is
when mike played by dennis reynolds
himself glenn howerton arrives at the
house in response to james's upset voice
message mike's a good pal his friend's
marriage proposal fell through and here
he is at god knows what hour to pick up
the pieces unfortunately mike's good
intentions lead to his demise waltzing
into the house oblivious of the
situation he shot in the face by james's
itchy trigger finger to be fair when a
person blows their best friend's face
off the first reaction isn't typically
to steal his cell phone even as an
audience member it's easy to forget that
mike has a phone that could be kristin
and james's chance to contact the police
after the incident james announces that
he's going to try and call for help not
by checking his dead friend's pockets
but by venturing out for the two-way
radio in the woods to be fair the movie
wants us to forget that mike has a cell
phone so that it can make a dramatic
appearance in the final act bleeding out
on the floor kristen hears mike's phone
ring something we didn't even realize
was there
upon coming to lash to a chair kristen
breathlessly asks the trio what we've
all been wondering why are you doing
this to us
because you were home this attack has
nothing to do with kristen and james's
relationship struggles with the apparent
wealth of james's family or with any
sinister occult purpose they answered
the door it's just that random and
simple indeed the scariest thing about
the strangers isn't the masks the jump
scares or the bloodshed instead the film
offers a glimpse into the terrifying
notion that sometimes bad things happen
just because there's no grand reveal and
no explanation for our villains actions
when the assailants remove their masks
kristen and james don't recognize their
faces the killers are as the film title
suggests just strangers
this hits especially hard in these final
moments even at the film's end there are
no answers all we're left with is pure
dread because we know so little about
these anonymous boogeymen they are able
to remain just that something that can
go bump in the night without any warning
or purpose the conclusion isn't here to
satisfy your curiosity
satisfied with the damage they've
inflicted our now unmasked trio exit
james's summer house and pile into their
pickup their truck passes two mormon
boys walking their bikes on the side of
the road they stop and chat with the
boys then continue down the road as they
drive away pinup girl makes a curious
comment to dollface she says
it'll be easier next time the internet
loves theorizing and passionate
redditors believe pinup's comment may
imply that the events we see in the film
were an initiation right of sorts for
dollface indeed if you look at the
trio's masks and their credited names a
sort of hierarchy emerges man in mask
never speaks he's a dominating presence
who towers over his two smaller peers
pinup girl always appears assured and
well practiced with a name suggesting a
degree of maturity dollface meanwhile is
another story a weak voice beneath a
wide-eyed childish mask it's possible
that she's new to this this
interpretation potentially puts pinup
girl's comment that it will be easier
next time into context dollface's
struggle with the acts she's committed
is further implied by her interactions
with the mormon boys she's a sinner and
she's a little shaken up by what she's
just done but next time it won't be her
first rodeo
the idea for the strangers came from a
number of different real-life sources
while you have to go digging through the
film's bonus features and production
notes to uncover how writer director
brian burtino's own brush with home
invasion inspired the film the ending of
the strangers hammers home some of the
film's more well-known sources as our
unmasked trio pile into their pickup
truck the connective tissue to the
famous tate labianca murders is
unavoidable as bertino recounted in an
interview the film was indeed in direct
conversation with the murders enacted by
the manson family bertino explained that
learning about the story of charles
manson and his followers along with the
group's seeming lack of any singular
motivation had a massive impact on him
and his understanding of the minds of
killers writer brit hayes notes another
source of inspiration for the film this
incident is known as the kitty cabin
murders an unsolved quadruple homicide
that took place in a california railroad
town in 1981 one of the most unnerving
similarities between the strangers and
the kitty cabin murders takes place
during the film's conclusion with
kristen and james bound to chairs in
their living room and stabbed in the
early morning the scene bears a strong
resemblance to the fates of some of the
case's victims
love him or hate him jump scares are an
essential part of horror films while not
all screamers as they're sometimes
called are created equal some are nobler
than others the word stingers describes
the jump scare that gives the audience
one last jolt before the credits roll
and believe it or not it's a
time-honored tradition there's the dream
sequence at the end of carrie for
instance where our witchy heroine's
bloodied arm bursts out of her rocky
grave to snatch the traumatized suit and
who could forget the final shot of the
franchise originator friday the 13th
when jason's decomposing corpse springs
out of crystal lake for one final shock
a final jump scare is a totally
acceptable if a bit silly way to end a
horror film the strangers keeps that
tradition alive as the two mormon boys
who are going to need some serious
therapy after this venture into the
house they spy james and kristen's
mangled bodies and investigate hovering
over kristen the boys take in the crime
scene with a frankly eerie silence dumb
struck perhaps at the gruesome bloodbath
before them one boy hovers over
kristen's body extending his hand
towards her face then bam kristen comes
to you screaming cut to black
considering the film's nihilistic
attitude kristin's survival is initially
surprising but upon closer inspection
the assailants leaving her alive gives
us some disturbing insight into the
killer's psyche they are not concerned
with the act of killing or even being
caught all that interests them is the
violence rhyme
reason or consequence be damned
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]